présider la république c'est être
viscéralement attaché à la laïcité car
c'est une valeur qui libère et qui
protège le sujet de la laïcité par
rapport à l'immigration
c'est puissance 10
faire une loi contre une liberté c'est
rentrer dans un engrenage terrible
ne croyez pas ça va devenir simple parce
que vous avez proféré sur le ton du
commandement une règle c'est un problème
politique
ça se règle pas uniquement avec des
questions sociales on n'entend pas
beaucoup la gauche défendre la laïcité
comme étant une valeur de gauche
personne n'a envie d'être traité de
raciste de dégueulasse surtout s'il ne
l'est pas il faut éviter d'utiliser des
mots dont on sait bien nous qu'ils sont
peu piégé
la laïcité à la française
modèle unique au monde s'est imposé
depuis plus d'un siècle comme élément
central de notre identité politique
c'est l'irruption de l'islam deuxième
religion du pays la plus vivace qui
remet la laïcité au coeur des débats
notamment ceux de la gauche
comment cet outil de la république
peut-il nous et d intégrer l'islam et à
combattre l'islamisme
c'est la gauche qui est à l'origine de
la grande loi de 1905
destiné à l'époque à contenir
l'hégémonie d'une autre religion
au début du 20e siècle le catholicisme
structure du baptême aux obsèques
la vie des français et mène un combat
idéologique contre la république la
france à la fois fille aînée de l'église
mère de la révolution décide alors de
séparer le spirituel du temporel
l'église de l'état
s'il ya un seul article à lire que tout
le monde doit connaître par coeur c'est
la république assure la liberté de
conscience
point donc la loi de 1905 c'est d'abord
le fait que chacun a le droit librement
enchante for intérieur de croire ou de
ne pas croire en fait la laïcité c'est
pas une valeur au sens où liberté
égalité fraternité sont des valeurs
c'est un principe politique
l'église chez elle l'état chez lui pour
élaborer le texte fondateur de la
laïcité
deux personnalités de la gauche
républicaine s'affrontent
aristide briand député républicain
socialiste promoteur d'une position
libérale il cherche un équilibre
favorisant d'abord la liberté de
conscience face à lui l'anticlérical
emile combes qui prône des solutions
radicales engagées dans un combat
spirituel idéologique contre le
catholicisme la gauche radicale qui se
reconnaissaient dans après cette série
comme les corbeaux comme d'autres titre
accusait reste-il brion d'être trop mou
envers les intégristes et considérer que
d'ailleurs l'église était en soit écrit
ce qui n'était pas complètement faux à
l'époque l'église en soi avait de telles
prétentions politiques sur la vie des
autres qu'on peut considérer qu'à
l'époque l'église catholique en soi
était déjà intégrée s'il ya une
proposition d'interdire que le clergé
hayon tenue clérical dans les rues alors
bon là un certain gérard barron c'est
trop et s'habille comme ils veulent
voyager pas que t'es pas des débats six
nouveaux essais ce qui a permis à briand
d'apparaître comme le juste milieu de
pouvoir dire vous voyez je ne vais pas
aller jusqu'à vous interdire de
pratiquer votre religion ni de croire je
vous demande de respecter l'espace
public et la liberté de conscience
l'ambiance tourne à l'insurrection dans
les régions les plus catholiques le
débat public est chauffé à blanc par la
presse aristide briand trouve quand même
la voie d'un compromis autour de ces
thèses libérales
la loi est votée il lui aura fallu trois
longues années pour convaincre et au
fond ce qui a toujours fait les listes
ne la force de la gauche et sa capacité
de ce1 de synthèse alors les
républicains ont fait surgir de terre un
imaginaire collectif qui s'appelle la
république et l'idée que le peuple est
souverain
la loi de 1905 dit judaïsme
protestantisme à égalité avec le culte
majoritaire dominant pareil mêmes droits
on oublie une quatrième religion l'islam
pour cause coloniale donc la république
elle s'est libérée de cette emprise ça a
été dur elles n'étaient pas préparés à
voir une autre offensive au fond d'une
autre religion
et elle n'a pas vu venir
et bien sûr entre foi religieuse et
fanatisme
il n'y a qu'une étroite frontières qu'il
est parfois difficile à définir
trois jeunes filles musulmanes qui
s'opposent à leurs professeurs et aux
dirigeants du collège motif elles
veulent afficher en permanence les
signes extérieurs de leur religion le
foulard plus précisément le ziff
marocain que porte fatima et leïla
selon leurs convictions musulmane le
problème n'est pas des croyances le
problème et de la manifestation
extérieure de cette croyance dans
l'enceinte des locaux scolaires et
notamment en classe ils nous acceptent
de mettre le foulard on y va à l'école
et puis s'il veut pas qu'on mettre le
foulard et ben n'y peut rien nous a
renvoyé la j'habite au cours dans les
hauts-de-seine le supplicié robinson une
ville à l'époque très ouvrière on a
encore un parti communiste qui est un
parti de masse très implanté dans les
cités et c est donc ça se passe bien on
n'a pas deux il n'y a pas de
confrontation entre les familles les
individus moi je suis au lycée à massy
dans l'essonne
il ya des gens de toutes origines de
toutes confessions de tout de toute
religion c'est un débat qui m'a semblé à
l'époque qui me semble être un débat de
vieux les militants politiques que nous
étions se disait quoi quoi quoi on n'a
plus droit de manifester son opinion au
lycée au collège mais on avait tous les
ans notre petit faucilles et marteaux
les autres notre main de fatma les cinq
doigts la touche pas à mon pote
[Applaudissements]
c'est la gauche au pouvoir c'est le
second septennat de françois mitterrand
on est après 86 et la mort de malik
oussékine c'est aussi apple est
redécouverte de la deuxième génération
parce que la première génération
d'immigrés
c'était une immigration essentiellement
masculine
sauf que ce que peut-être les
sociologues et les politiques n'avaient
pas prévu c'est que ces immigrés un
vérin et leurs femmes et il avait fait
des enfants et nous on était là avec des
problématiques nouvelles pas les mêmes
que nos parents en fait toi parce que
nous on avait pris conscience
même si nos parents et moi mon père
continue et nous dire on retrouvera en
algérie nous savait parfaitement que
c'était plus possible par même très
rapidement vous avez pris position vous
avez dit finalement le jean n'en portera
sur le tchador
je suis contre moi à titre personnel il
faut laisser cette jeune fille parce que
c'est le meilleur moyen de pas les
exclure alors j'estime effectivement que
nous ne devons pas les laisser sous
prétexte de provocation faire main basse
sur ses enfants et qu'il faut au
contraire que ces enfants là malgré le
fait que dans leur environnement
familial à leur environnement
intégristes on avenue les affubler d'un
foulard ils puissent quand même aller à
l'école parce que là ils seront au
contact d'un autre univers
parce que par l'acquisition des
connaissances et bien ils pourront
effectivement eux aussi avoir leur
chance et réussir l'intégration
si vous voulez on a d'abord pensé à nous
en dedans et c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est un piège
l'école n'est pas un lieu du vide
politique puisque on dit que la
république
elle a une mission d'émancipation une
mission une mission intégratrice m'aider
mais en fait si ces gamines ne vont pas
à l'école justement le sais parce que je
crois à l école républicaine je me dis
il faut faut les accepter
si aujourd'hui 200 ans après la laïcité
ne pouvait pas accueillir toutes les
religions toutes les les
les expressions en france alors ce qu'il
y aurait un recul terrible
si le voile est l'expression d'une
religion nous devons accepter les
traditions telles qu'elles sont je pense
que j'étais plutôt du côté danielle
mitterrand
parce que je vois là j'ai des jt jeu
j'ai accueilli le monde comme on dit
l'atelier le monde au nom des minorités
on y est mais bon c'est leur culture
face à cela le gouvernement est
relativement désarmées est ce que
vraiment la laïcité interdit le port de
signes religieux à l'école
le gouvernement de michel rocard se
trouve face à un dilemme comment
concilier les deux libertés essentielles
inscrite dans la loi de 1905 la liberté
de culte et la liberté de conscience
désormais concurrentes comme secrétaire
général de l'elysée naturellement je
parle avec le premier ministre michel
rocard le miz de l'éducation nationale
de nageuse pain et le président de la
république
en fait le président de la république
connaît la loi de 1905 bien entendu
comme il connaît notre histoire
il sait combien ça a été difficile et
important de sortir des conflits
violents de l'époque il est attaché
comme beaucoup d'autres responsables
politiques à la laïcité à une et si tu
es qui pour lui soit synonyme de liberté
et donc il a laissé le point ministre et
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
faire leur travail
il en résulte un texte une circulaire
qui parle du caractère ostentatoire
je préconise que les directeurs
d'établissements et les enseignants vise
à ses enfants et à leurs parents qu'ils
ne doit pas venir à l'école
dans ces conditions au début de sa
phrase on sait pas bien ce qu'il va dire
à la fin en fait on a le sentiment qui
va dire alors si on n'arrive pas à
régler
alors la circulaire j'aimerais clarifier
les choses et pas du tout si il y à
blocage et si il y a revu jeudi
alors l'école doit accepter et
accueillir ces enfants
donc on a le sentiment d'une certaine
manière qui votons touche qui renvoie
vers les chefs d'établissement disant
débrouillez vous alors le chef
d'établissement évalue s'il a affaire à
une gamine qui est un peu parti dans un
truc personnel si c'est du fondamental
ou pas si c'est politique ou pas bons on
a toujours fait comme cela c'est ça la
vertu de l'école laïque et républicaine
c'est non pas de rejeter mais d'amener
tout le monde a évolué comme ça je suis
dans l'hémicycle puisque je suis chargé
des relations avec l'assemblée nationale
au au cabinet du premier ministre au
cabinet de michel rocard et je vis comme
bien comme bientôt de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le début des tourments de la
gauche avec avec ses discussions avec
ses problèmes mais pas plus qu'on ne
juge l'église catholique à travers
monseigneur lefebvre
on ne doit voir derrière chaque
musulmane et d'intégristes en puissance
il répliquait un argument qui n'était
pas vraiment présent qui est de dire oui
mais le il divo si chaque foulard on
voit derrière chaque musulmanes
intégristes on est à côté de la plaque
on pensait tout ça nous prenons la
mauvaise manière comment nous une pente
émotionnel et chacun réagit un peu avec
ses tripes sur cette question souhaite
que ce problème ne vient pas problème le
socialo socialiste les socialistes au
sens les les politiques ceux ci ses
dirigeants socialistes unanimement
mitterrand rocard jospin joxe me roy
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
globalement prennent la position dans le
sens d'une minimisation du phénomène
françois mitterrand était venu nous voir
une journée on était à saint malo et
après milieu d'un repas de poisson
le président qui avait une façon à lui
de dire son mécontentement
mais ils étaient très mécontents je le
sentais très bien m'a dit mais enfin
elisabeth de gamine avec un foulard sur
la tête ça menace pas la république
voyons c'est pas rien c'est pas c'est
pas du tout gênant et puis me dit il
elles sont charmantes ces petites jeunes
filles avec leur petit foulard la sphère
du voile islamique suite chaque jour
amène un nouveau cas d'école ou une ou
plusieurs jeunes filles veulent porter
le voile de leur religion pendant les
cours après une semaine d'expérience
fatima et leïla n'ont pas pu tenir
l'engagement de suivre les cours sans
foulard
le père a décidé d'agir vous avez pris
un avocat
oui vous vous battez sous quels
principes principe de la liberté de
méfaits qui s'habille comme unique le
voile c'est un droit le voile fait le
preneur touchez pas à notre honneur sur
ce flanc gauche et au prix d'allah akbar
allah est grand
700 personnes de manifester boulevard
magenta cet après midi et c'est là aussi
où je me suis rendu compte à quel point
les politiques et l h dans certaines
circonstances vraiment parce qu enfin au
bout d'un moment il fallait être naïf ou
détourner son regard pour ne pas voir
que ces deux jeunes filles étaient
évidemment manipuler
en fait dans l'impasse à creil d une
semaine solide et refusent la présence
au tour des jeunes filles au foulard
rentrée tendue au collège de creil où
les enseignants ont décidé de s'opposer
au port du foulard islamique dans les
salles de cours
leurs professeurs ont refusé de recevoir
tant qu'elles porteront le foulard
c'était un mépris des principes
républicains
comment deux gamines décide que ça leur
convient pas et qu'on a qu'à s'adapter à
elle je suis rappelle d'une de loeb soit
du nouvel obs qui était prof ne
capitulons pas avec eux je crois
finkielkraut debré badinter yade je vais
il avait de fontenay je pense que
c'était les quatre qui était à
l'initiative de cet appel est large le
dit tiens c'est du solide c'est du
costaud
leur position c'était dire si on accepte
ça c'est le début de la fin on est tous
enseignants donc l'école à cette époque
en tous les cas pour nous l'école
publique c'était sacré c'était le lieu
où on pouvait développer la liberté de
penser de juger des enfants de l'est
comment dirais-je de leur ouvrir
l'univers familial aussi de 2 de leur
apprendre la liberté de pensée on veut
des musulmans qui n'est pas l'air
musulmans dont 89
c'est une c'est un désastre
intellectuelle de ce point de vue
puisque ce qu'on retiendra c'est ce
texte signé dans le nouvel observateur
avec ce mot le munich de l'alcool
républicaine seppois munich
alors il ya hitler là qui a le fascisme
il ya un espèce de choc jaillir
traditionnelle entre deux partis de la
gauche une partie qui est plutôt de
caractère libertaire libéral démocrate
et puis d'autres plus républicain plus
féministe aussi plus universaliste donc
féministe représenté par parce que dit
gisèle halimi alors le tchador ça n'est
pas seulement religieux ces politiques
ne nous y trompons guerre
et c'est surtout et c'est là que je veux
en venir c'est tout même le symbole de
la soumission et de l'infériorisation de
la femme gisèle halimi se trompe je
crois que ce n'est pas en prenant comme
bouc émissaire ces jeunes filles qu'on
fera avancer leur émancipation qu'on
fera avancer leur intégration en france
je n'ai pas trouvé encore une seule
réaction où on parle enfin de la femme
car tout de même c'est tchador c'est
pour la femme c'est pas pour l'homme la
position que la plus stricte c'est à
dire celle de gisèle halimi a été très
soutenue par les féministes et
effectivement qui était une bonne partie
aussi de la gauche la gauche plus rose
je dirais que rouge je crois qu'il y a
dans l'histoire de la gauche française
une gauche qui pense que y compris
vis-à-vis d'autres peuples ou du peuple
en son sein qu'elle sait quel est le
juste et bon chemin
sa fracture des familles politiques ou
d'idées qui étaient eux qui étaient
assez proches voire voir ayed boudjema
interpellé gisèle halimi bon on imagine
que pour une jeune femme de sa
génération c'est pas rien ouais on est
tous perturbé il faut pas raconter
d'histoire parce que même tant d'années
après je les entends et j'éprouve la
même impression tout le monde a raison
au bout de plusieurs semaines de
polémique la circulaire jospin ne suffit
pas à régler la situation le
gouvernement en appelle au conseil
d'état les conseillers d'état ne tranche
pas il se contente de dire le droit
le conseil d'état dit en l'absence d'une
loi on ne peut pas interdire
systématiquement le port de signes
religieux en l'occurrence du foulard à
l'école mais par contre on peut le
limiter voire interdire dans le cas où
il fait une action de propagande de
procès dit isme les jeunes filles savent
désormais que pour retourner à l'école
il leur faudra ôter le voile mais rien
n'est précisé pour les contraindre
est ce que oui ou non
c'était pour elle obligatoire est ce que
pour être de bonne musulmane elle était
obligée de le faire ou non
d'abord c'est la première fois que
j'entends parler de foule à coranique
vous avez lu la presse française la soie
certains n'ont même pas franchement
parce que si je l'avais lu je re
immédiatement émis une fatwa édit si toi
c'est l'arrêt désolé mais c'est un
sacrilège que de mettre les saintes
écritures sur des tissus qui peuvent
être souillée qu'on le veuille ou non il
n'est pas question de porter un voile
sous une forme ou sous une autre
quel que soit le nom qu'on lui donne on
peut ne pas les interdire pour telle
fiche ici et là des bigoudis ce jour là
ce qui n'est pas recommandé en classe
d'autre au fond on aurait dû prendre ça
comme une
comme une preuve de l'offensive
politique parce que dès que le roi du
maroc a dit stop ça s'arrêtait si on
avait tout de suite dit non et si le
conseil d'état au lieu de 200 mails et
pardonnez-moi les pinceaux à dire oui
non aussi ceci si cela je pense que ça
serait arrêtée mais c'était un test et
atteste de notre résistance et ça on l'a
pas vu et la gauche ne l'a pas vu mais
en 89 je me suis trompé parce que j'ai
été moi je dirais influencé par le conte
est
j'étais dans une démarche de soutien à
des gens pointer du doigt à cause de
leur religion et en plus on a toujours
en mémoire les guerres coloniales et c
est donc on pointait du doigt des hommes
et des femmes issus d'une immigration
ciblés etc
donc je me suis mis dans la défense de
ces jeunes filles
c'est vrai qu'entre temps d'aujourd'hui
je reparle avec certains de ces
intellectuels qui ont pas ou est ce
qu'ils sont des amis qui ont qui a
annoncé cet appel des gens pour qui j'ai
de l'admiration notamment et du respect
l'estimé et qui me disent mais ses deux
petites filles vous n'êtes donc pas vu
qu'elle était manipulé de deux jeunes
filles comme ça elle ne pouvait être que
manipuler banon on ne l'a pas eu
certains et certaines ces intellectuels
comme elisabeth badinter la file
quelques routes
gisèle halimi anticipe et surtout
transgresse du point de vue de la gauche
l'idée qu'être laïque refusé le voile le
tchador lutter contre l'intégrisme
c'est pas être de droite ou d'extrême
droite c'est profondément républicain et
donc les hommes et les femmes de gauche
peuvent parfaitement tenir ses positions
je le comprendrais plus tard
fatima il est là sont maintenant en
troisième et elles se rendent comme tous
les matins en collège gabrielle hallez
elles sont les seuls parmi les élèves à
porter encore le foulard un foulard
qu'elle enlève néanmoins une fois
franchie la porte de l'établissement
[Musique]
à l'époque a pas internet
à l'époque tout le monde se rachète vous
savez c'est énorme parabole qu'on va
retrouver partout dans toutes les cités
et peu à peu on voit bien que la
télévision française
elle a de moins en moins droit de cité
dans les foyers que la télévision
algérienne ou marocaine
en tout cas moi même quand je vais dans
ma famille c'est canal algérie qui est
branché en permanence à cette époque là
bien sûr c'est la liberté des gens les
gens regardent ce qu'ils veulent mais on
voit bien quand même que il se passe
quelque chose à ce moment-là banani
c'est avant tout le président du seul
parti politique religieux le fise front
islamique de salut
six mois d'existence 3 millions de
sympathisants peut être beaucoup plus la
prière vient de se terminer
ils scandent l'état islamique
quand la répression les tombées sur les
militants du fis en algérie on en a reçu
par un dans le jilin dans le département
on a reçu d'ailleurs un peu moins de
démocrates algériens qui étaient
poursuivis que de queuleu que de
militants islamistes et la principales
mouvances qui va travailler au corps
vraiment ces jeunes c'est la mouvance
des frères musulmans qui va commencer a
très discrètement les recruter les
endoctriner leur dire que la république
les oppriment leur dire que la
république des tests l'islam détestent
leur religion dans notre vie interne
déjà de militants et de militantes
alors qu'on se donnait du camarade à
tout bout de champ on va passer du
camarade au frère et à la soeur il ya
une vraie sédition qui est en train
d'organiser ya des groupes qui souffle
sur ces flammes qui ont compris qu'il
fallait absolument pousser les gamins à
créer des tensions au sein de l'école
pour pour tester aussi sa tolérance et
du coup ses professeurs ne s'en sortent
plus il appelle à l'aide
les politiques tous les enfants de
france
quelles que soient leurs origines
quelles que soient leurs croyances sont
les filles et les fils de la république
jacques chirac réélu en 2002 face au
front national décide de faire preuve de
fermeté sur le front de la laïcité le
voile islamique la qui part ou une croix
de manifestement deux dimensions
excessive n'ont pas leur place dans les
enceintes des écoles publiques jacques
chirac répond ainsi à la pression des
chefs d'établissement qui veulent des
règles claires il décide de bannir le
port du voile à l'école et nomme d'abord
une commission la commission stasi pour
étudier la possibilité d'une loi
d'interdiction et chirac créé une
commission avec deux parlementaires mais
reste ont été vains c'était un mélange
l'universitaire de deux spécialistes du
sujet de terre et donc je suis désignée
par le groupe socialiste pour être à
porter de sucre participer à cette
commission est portée pour travailler
sur le sujet et j'y vais avec à la fois
ma position de 89 sur le thème comme
l'immense majorité des socialistes
sous-estiment en offensive et dans le
travail de la mission d'information sur
le de préparation de ce projet doit je
change d'avis nous avons constaté que
dans ceux plénée les enseignants étaient
une réalité qu'il y avait dans les cours
de récréation et jusque dans les salles
de classe des groupes de garçons qui
faisait pression sur les filles qu'il
percevait comme entre guillemets
musulmane alors qu'ils ont la loi te
permet de porter le voile si tu ne le
porte pas c'est donc que tu as décidé de
ne pas le porter
donc tu fais une mauvaise musulmane d
une [ __ ] ça on va te faire on va te
régler ton compte
à la récré et je suis frappé mes
collègues quelles que soient leurs
convictions politiques le sont aussi par
des témoignages très précis qui sont
apportés par des chefs d'établissement
par des fédérations de parents d'élèves
par des enseignants
dix ans il ya des cas où on voit bien
que le voile c'est un peu une crise
d'adolescence ça pourrait être du
piercing aujourd'hui on dirait du
gothique mais nous avons eu le cas qui
n'est pas isolé de gens qui venaient
avec des armées d'avocats
connaissant parfaitement la
jurisprudence du conseil d'état la cour
en panne et toit de la maison qui
faisait une pression politique
nous découvrons la réalité de
l'offensive idéologique de l'islam
politique et je la découvre en
particulier parce que ça m'a beaucoup
marquée par un document qui équipe dont
l'auteur s'appelle abdallah 1100 qui est
un guide pour les islamistes pour
déstabiliser le l'école de la république
un guide comment faire qu'on prête
concrètement pour déstabiliser l'école
de la république et combattre la laïcité
et ce qui je pense a été le point de
bascule des auditions pendant la
commission stasi c'est que les jeunes
femmes qui viennent en demandant qu'on
garde la protection de la de l'école
républicaine sans signes religieux sont
des jeunes femmes qui demande à parler à
visage caché sans être potentiellement
reconnu parce qu'elles ont peur des
pressions ils ont peur des menaces et
quand elles sont dans ce huis clos avec
les gens de la commission à leurs 10
protéger nous et je n'ai plus eu aucune
hésitation il faut que la république
dise non
quelle table sur le tas mais qu'elle dit
ça c'est interdit
les milliers de personnes dans la rue
pour une même cause la défense des
droits des femmes
ici le seul mot d'ordre c'est laïcité et
il se chante
résultat carton plein une nouvelle
génération féministes qui rejoint les
militante de la première heure avec
lille ni [ __ ] ni soumises tout au début
avec fadela amara au siège du parti
place que le nail fabien parce que
justement c'était une association au
féminisme nouvelle qui portait des des
valeurs différentes un peu du mouvement
féministe on se prend une flopée
d'insultés
on nous dit qu'on s'est acoquiné avec la
droite que c'est la droite qui fait qui
a fait kiffer cette loi que sait on que
et on est obligé de faire un tract pour
rappeler quelques petites choses du
passé en leur disant que la loi sur
l'île et g vous l'avez quand même voter
et pourtant c'était une ministre de
droite
s'il l'a proposé et qui qu'il a élaboré
le féminisme étaient quand même à
l'époque porté par des femmes
principalement et des hommes mais d'un
certain niveau social d'un certain
niveau intellectuel c'était quand même
quelque chose d'assez réservé d'assez le
but de ni [ __ ] ni soumises c'était
vraiment de faire en sorte que ça ça
éclosent dans les quartiers le mouvement
ni [ __ ] ni soumises à permis je pense
d'eux réveillée et souhaite racisme qui
a été assez courageux sur ce dossier qui
a changé d'avis profondément on écoute
on quoi en écoutant les filles des
quartiers
beaucoup de femmes ne sont pas
spécialement pour cette loi en tout cas
l'inquiétude qu'elle on s'est quand même
la prégnance du religieux dans leur vie
et toutes ces femmes nous disent nous on
veut que nos filles zahia l'école autres
cortèges autre discours
une petite centaine de personnes
manifestent contre la loi sur la laïcité
leur point de vue sur le droit des
femmes est bien différent des autres
pour le droit à l'éducation
tu te revendique féminisme étape à
régler point même ton problème parce
qu'à un moment donné il faut se poser la
question du voile mais c'est une
injonction qui est faite aux femmes
elle est pourquoi l ai pas fait aux
hommes non moi ça je peux pas l'accepter
parce que le voile c'est quand même le
symbole d'une soumission faut pas faux
pas il n'y a pas de raison de donner aux
voiles la signification qu'il n'a pas
parce qu'au fond ce serait les femmes
qui seraient responsables des dérives
sexuelles des hommes et on peut parler
de féminisme dans ce cas là mais c'est
une blague et une black beaucoup ont
d'ailleurs entériné un à ben ben oui
c'est ça la liberté
ben non c'est pas vrai pour moi ni [ __ ]
ni soumises a été vraiment comme sos
racisme
l'expression la caricature de cette
gauche qui pense qu'elle est le bien et
qu'elle va le dire le bien aux classes
populaires des quartiers et les
quartiers les quartiers le peuple des
quartiers ce qu'on met en ghettos comme
ça qu'on regarde dont hélas on est ou
coeur encore une fois de commandes à une
gauche n'est plus de gauche en voulant
légiférer dans la précipitation on fait
du voile un symbole qui marquerait qui
se remarquerait par des crispations dans
la société donc je crois que c'est
plutôt par le dialogue que l'on fera
reculer l'intégrisme je suis maire
d'evry je suis député et je vois bien ce
qui se passe dans dans cette petite
société de de la ville d'evry où
beaucoup de français ou ou d'étrangers
de confession ou de culture musulmane je
le vois dans dans mon équipe donc
j'hésite pour pour toutes ces raisons
mais je n'hésiterai pas très longtemps
il se passe quand même un événement qui
nous a nous a quand même bien
bouleverser et c'est une cassette audio
qui est distinctif la casse est là audio
qui est distribué dans pratiquement
toutes les boîtes de la cité en moi je
ne sais pas aimer des trucs religieux
dedans on se fait traduire la cassette
audio
elle est quand même très violente c'est
une cassée
est en fait qui appelle les femmes à ne
pas suivre donc le courant qui est
pourtant cette loi de 2004 c'était
c'était très très très chaud à dans la
cité c'était voilà et nous on prend
position à ce moment là de manière très
très un peu violente aussi en disant que
nous on laissera on est pour le vote de
cette loi il n'y a quasiment pas de
débat au sein du groupe socialiste il ya
quasiment pas de débat et est donc le
nous décidons de voter la loi
la séance est reprise
le projet de loire n'est pas rédigé
contre une population ou contre une
religion la république garantit à tous
la liberté de pratiquer la religion de
son choix et nous avons réagi à la
hauteur de la tentative défaire des
jeunes frères musulmans de d'impôt faire
imposer le voile dans les écoles
publiques de la république
si je vois un élève avec une croix comme
ça hier j'en ai vu des plus grosses bas
je lui demande de la cacher sous son
pull
mais alors là je lui demanderais
vraiment de la cacher parce que bon ça
ça me paraît quand même assez visible et
puis je dirais marqué une petite
médaille comme ça ça pose pas de
problème on a justement voulu ne pas
être excessif quinze ans après l' alerte
des intellectuels républicain le voile
est bannie de l'école publique
le ps votent la loi avec une partie de
la droite et la gauche politique se
divise
le projet de loi a été adopté je me suis
de nouveau trompé puisque je n'ai pas
voté la loi sur le port du voile à
l'école
oui il fallait une belle loi sur la
laïcité vous pouvez se donnait
d'ailleurs juste à 2007 s'il aurait
permis de bien fêter le centenaire la
loi de 1905 féliciter mais une loi qui
prenne en compte l'ensemble des
problèmes
la loi n'est pas faite pour être dire la
loi les fautifs pour construire si je
devais aujourd'hui revoter c'est toi je
la voterai parce que c'est facile de
dire ça bien sûr parce que elle a fait
ses preuves
parce que quand vous allez à la pente
des lycées chez moi ça se passe bien ça
se passe souvent le sourire ça se passe
souvent d'hommes dans l'épicentre et
cetera voilà non dans les rangs
socialistes aussi c'était pas clair
et puis de bons de bons camarades chez
les écologistes
les écologistes s'étaient plutôt contre
contre 7 contre cette loi
et pourtant les écologistes dont ils
sont nés d'une tradition qui est une
tradition assez universaliste on
pourrait dire sauf que dans la réalité
des positions politiques dans le champ
souvent on est aussi un parti qui est
attentif à la lutte contre le racisme
comme d'autres très attentif aux au
régionalisme très attentive à la défense
des identités minoritaires et nos
sciences et ont été traversés d'abord
par le même débat et puis on s'est
retrouvé pris au piège
pris au piège de la même manière c'est
une des plus sales période de ma vie
militante
parce que je me dis que quelques fois
j'ai passé beaucoup plus de temps à me
battre avec eux et que et qu'elle crie
souvent contre eux pour leur expliquer
l'utilité de cette loi j'y suis allé
voir des élus en leur disant vous vous
rendez compte que cette cassette a été
mise dans toutes les boîtes aux lettres
des gens qui avaient été repérés comme
étant musulman ça veut dire que ces gens
là ils ont les moyens à l'événement
majeur aussi qui se greffent dans tout
ce débat ce sont les émeutes de 2005
avec également dans certains territoires
notamment en seine-saint-denis le rôle
d'aidé religieux comme
ap d'heure 2 de tension les entreprises
les bâtiments publics et même les écoles
aucun édifice collectif n'a été épargné
7/10 d'abord l'échec de la gauche au
pouvoir à offrir par l'école une
solution une solution d'intégration le
fameux modèle méritocratique républicain
c'est un mythe qui est mobilisateur et
rassembleur lorsqu'il fonctionne 2005
signe me semble-t-il l'échec de
l'intégration à la française je
caricature je vais évidemment trop vite
il ya des gens qui ont choisi
d'instrumentaliser les thématiques post
coloniale pour au nom de ces thématiques
postcoloniale imposer un agenda
politique ultra religieux on a depuis 89
re donner crédit à ce qui était le
poison de la question coloniale l'arabe
le musulman c'est ça notre problème et
c'est ça le coeur alors bien sûr en
retour évidemment que cela crée des
radicalités en retour vous nous désigner
comme saab a d'autant plus partout où on
allait on ne discutait que de ça ils
nous aiment pas en gros c'était ce qu'on
a on entendait il nous aime pas y
compris des gens qui avaient été plutôt
un progressif des jambes
ils veulent pas de nous et ils veulent
pas de nous parce qu'on est musulman il
en souriant talise l'humiliation vécue
par les parents puis par les enfants
dans avait vu si vous font ça vous avez
vu comment se payer vous traite et
maintenant après vous avoir fait tout ça
en plus ils vous impose une loi qui est
une loi contre l'islam ça c'est le
discours des islamistes et et d'une
certaine manière la hausse est terrible
c'est que même une loi la loi de 2004
qui était fait pour empêcher leur
avancée en fait d'une certaine manière
tous leurs tous leurs faits tous leurs
faits profit puisqu'ils ont vendu cette
loi comme étant une loi de
stigmatisation
l'ambassade du danemark prises d'assaut
jets de pierres incendient la scène se
passe à damas elle se répétera dans
plusieurs pays musulmans ce qui a mis le
feu aux poudres
ce sont des dessins des caricatures
principalement celles représentant
mahomet coiffé d'un turban en forme de
bombe
on suit cette affaire la sphère du
ghilan boston et de ce concours de
caricatures organisé par notamment
flemming rose le patron du new york post
punk est un journal de centre
l'ambassadeur du danemark venu rendre
visite au président du conseil français
du culte musulman
la france compte le plus grand nombre de
musulmans en europe 5 millions de
fidèles qui selon leurs représentants
sont choqués par l'humour danois
le directeur de la rédaction de france
soir se dire on parle beaucoup de cette
affaire donc il faut au moins que les
gens sachent de quel dessein il s'agit
et publie les dessins hier soir
l'actionnaire principal du quotidien
français a limogé son directeur de la
publication en signe fort de respect des
croyances de chaque individu
moi je dis il faut qu'on les publics
tous je téléphone à mes collègues et
pour leur demander s'ils sont d'accord
pour publier dans la semaine
ces [ __ ] de caricatures bon et la
plupart sont d'accord on fait une une
on met mahomet notre côté on fait un
mahomet qui est effondrée par l'attitude
des intégristes
cabu arrive à faire cette une après des
nuits de débats entre nous qui est à la
fois anti raciste et l'oeil qui protège
les musulmans et qui cible les
intégristes c'est bien la colère
explique ces musulmans qui les a poussés
à descendre dans la rue pour dénoncer la
publication des caricatures de marc
mettre dans des journaux français
on a l'impression que c'est une partie
de ce qu'on sait lecture
oui à la grée portée de pression mais
non à l'audi formation allait à minuit
le mercredi je pense je reçois un coup
de fil de ces revues lis qui me dit ma
fille je te préviens ça va pas être
agréable pour toi demain parce que on va
te pourrir dans libé on est contre
finalement on a changé d'avis et c'était
un prof effectivement le lendemain dans
libé ans faisait courir la gueule le new
york times a titré qu'on se moquait des
musulmans réellement il a fait croire
il faut dire que en 1905 le new york
times avait déjà titré que la loi de
séparation était une atteinte à la
liberté religieuse
donc ils n'ont pas changé d'avis sur ce
sujet donc on sait on est lâché
on est lâché on est lâché par le peloton
c'est pas nous qui accéléreront c'est le
peloton qui freine donc on part en
danseuse comme des cons devant tout seul
tout seul saisir en pleine visibilité
pour le monde entier
plusieurs organisations musulmanes
voulait empêcher la parution de ce
numéro spécial de charlie hebdo à la une
du journal satirique
ce dessin de cabu qui présente une
nouvelle caricatures du prophète mahomet
san insultes que les terroristes san
insulte pas du tout les musulmans
le dessin et la rancune aucune
méchanceté nous se sentent insultés
je vois pas pourquoi nous on défend le
pauvre
or contre les intégristes ou alors ils
sont tous des intéristes moi j'ai
demandé à des personnalités à l'époque
de bords différents de droite comme de
centre comme béroud et puis françois
hollande qu'elle est première secrétaire
du parti socialiste et à des
personnalités musulmanes de venir
témoigner en notre faveur et le journal
s'offrent une tribune douze témoins
intellectuelle et politique
la scène vaudrait presque une caricature
filmer dans la salle des témoins un
premier secrétaire du ps
un écrivain un enseignant une
historienne
recule un peu
souffre et être bien conscience devient
c'est fini on ne peut pas atteindre une
liberté aussi essentiel que la liberté
d'expression
je crois pas qu'on rende service prix
compris même aux religions en général à
ce moment là les hommes politiques
soutenaient charlie en tous les cas sur
la liberté d'expression
pas question de remettre en cause la
liberté de la presse dit-on sur le banc
de la partie selon l'union des
organisations islamiques de france
la grande mosquée de paris et la ligue
islamique mondiale sont les trois
organisations qui poursuivent charlie
pour injures publiques
[Musique]
le procès était très tendue il y avait
des menaces on était sous haute
protection
il y avait donc les avocats de l'unef de
la mosquée et de la ligue islamique
mondiale qui étaient ce les travées d'en
face et à un moment donné de fatigue
parce qu'il faisait chaud parce que les
débats étaient tendues parce que de
temps en temps
kezman qui était un mais deux avocats et
malka mais kezman était formidable il a
dit des trucs très marrant qui ont fait
marrer par moments tout le monde et nous
mêmes
enfin on brandissait des choses qu'on
avait fait contre l'église contre
l'absinthe vierge ce bois qui fuit les
gens voulaient pas rire mais au bout
d'un moment ils se marraient quand même
bon donc il y avait une espèce
d'ambiance de tension mais de notre côté
d espèce de sas de dédramatisation où
toute la salle rigoler ou le président
angolais il disait allez arrêtez de rire
maintenant vraiment on y va on continue
un moment donné le président dit pause
on fait une pause parce que tout le
monde est fatigué on va boire un petit
coup de flottes ont appuyé c'est bon
tout est là dans les dents tout on est
assez dans l'allée centrale pour sortir
et ça on piétine et g contre mon épaule
le l'avocat de la ligue islamique
mondiale
on est tous les deux comme ça l'un
contre l'autre et il en profite pour me
dire monsieur val monsieur val je suis
contre tout ce que vous dites mais
j'aimerais bien être votre ami
ils me disent ah les braves peuvent
tomber parce qu'on est tellement serré
que les braves pas tomber non mais
mais il avait envie d'être avec des gens
qui rigolait il avait parce que le rire
partagé c'était un partage d'humanité
parce qu'ils s'étaient marées malgré lui
après lille a repris son rôle mais ça
veut dire quelque chose ça veut dire
qu'on peut y arriver
quand on prend pas les gens pour des
abrutis ça change tout on s'ouvre on se
comprend on n'a plus envie de s'arracher
les ongles on a envie de boire un coup
de discuter dire comment on peut faire
pour s'arranger je vais essayer de
convaincre moi aussi fabre voilà
l'humanité quoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
musulmans laïques et républicains c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour ceux qui croient
en la liberté d'expression
c'est une bonne nouvelle quand on pense
que c'est une nécessité pour faire
marcher les étapes droit une relaxe
arrosée ce soir dans les locaux de
charlie hebdo initialement tiré à 5000
exemplaires le numéro spécial incriminé
a été diffusée en février 2006 à plus de
400000 exemplaires
le jugement a bien tenu compte de la
distinction à faire entre les personnes
ils ne peuvent pas être attaqués selon
leur religion et la religion elle même
ça veut dire qu'ils ne sont pas allés au
delà la liberté d'expression après que
ça fasse mal que ça plaise que sap
l'espace avait partie du débat mais nous
sommes un pays libre les lois
démocratiquement votées c'est notre loi
c'est pas la religion qui est notre loi
on avait déjà eu tellement moi j'avais
des vins procès avec les avec des
catholiques de d'extrême droite on avait
pu pratiquement 20 avant donc l'islam
pour moi c'est un tout petit machin
pendant statistiquement parlant mais ils
ont fait des des caricatures sans doute
violentes à l'égard des ça mais qu'est
ce qu'ils avaient mis au pape et à jésus
[Musique]
religion catholique en a pris pour son
grade au nom de cette liberté de penser
à de cette liberté de conscience de
cette liberté d'expression et de cette
liberté de caricatures
et déjà l'après satirique anticlérical
de l'époque fait cette extraction très
claire elle attaque les idées elle
attaque les institutions elle attaque
les symboles mais elle n'attaque pas les
individus 4 ans plus tard charlie est de
nouveau pris pour cible dans la nuit
tôt ce matin un ou plusieurs individus
ont cassé une vitre de charlie hebdo
balancer un cocktail molotov à
l'intérieur et ce qui a eu pour résultat
d'enflammer partie des locaux je pense
pas que ce soit un mec bourré qui
rentrent de soirée qui a balancé un
cocktail molotov par hasard c'est une
déconnade sur le fait que la charia
risque d'être appliquée en libye est qu
un parti islamiste et arrive en tête des
élections en tunisie
charlie hebdo charia hebdo c'est juste
une énorme blog et tout le monde ne rit
pas les organisations religieuses ne
sont plus les seuls à s'en prendre à
charlie une vingtaine d'intellectuels
des universitaires de nouvelles
associations antiracistes comme les
indigènes de la république signe un
texte qui accuse charlie d'alimenter une
obsession anti musulmane de nouveaux
termes apparaissent dans le débat public
ce qui leur est arrivé
ça dit à quel point dans la cité
française on n'arrive pas à défendre
deux choses en même temps est ce qu'on a
le droit en france aujourd'hui de
défendre le droit le droit d'être
offrant 100 c'est vers la liberté les
frissons de charlie hebdo
quand même temps de défendre le droit de
se sentir offensés
l'argument qui consiste à dire je dis ça
mais c'est que de la blague c'est plus
un argument qui est qu'ils détiennent
il ya une hypersensibilité à la parole à
la parole dans son ensemble donc à la
parole à la parole humoristique et moi
je crois je pense que c'est je pense que
c'est plutôt bien en fait
les frères musulmans qui sont très
actifs dans toute cette histoire ne sont
sont des grands politiques se sont pas
du tout des abrutis
et quand ils voient qu'il ya toute une
intelligentsias comme on dit je n'aime
pas beaucoup ce mot un bond d'un pays
qui est qui les regarde avec
bienveillance
parce qu'ils sont censés représenter les
nouveaux humiliée et offensée les
nouveaux damnés de la terre les
musulmans ils se disent c'est bon on
peut y aller quoi on peut y aller on a
des relais médiatiques on a des relais
intellectuelle
on peut y aller présider la république
s'être glissé ralement attaché à la
laïcité en 2012 françois hollande fait
de la laïcité un axe majeur de son
projet présidentiel
jusqu'ici la campagne de françois
hollande frémit à peine et ses discours
ont plutôt tendance à être un peu
ennuyeux et ennuyé et au moment où il
prononce enfin le terme de laïcité comme
partie prenante de nos valeurs les plus
sacrées à ce moment là y'a ya un frisson
qui parcourt la salle ont longtemps et
on sent que la campagne d'école car
c'est une valeur qui libère et qui
protège et c'est pourquoi j'ai
inscrirait la loi de 1905
celle qui sépare les églises de l'état
dans la constitution
j'ai travaillé donc plus de dix ans à
ses côtés à la terrasse ont dû partir de
ces sujets ma conviction c'est que ça
fait partie des choses qui n'intéressent
pas françois hollande n'aime pas ces
sujets liés à la laïcité à l'immigration
il sent que cela divise la gauche et il
sent qu'on est sur un terrain il se
trompe semble-t-il mais collé sur un
terrain mouvant
une fois élu françois hollande renonce à
inscrire la loi de 1905 dans la
constitution
il préfère reprendre une idée jamais
mise en oeuvre de jacques chirac
constituer un observatoire de la laïcité
je pensais que c'était très bien
c'était très content qu'il ya un
observatoire de la laïcité
je me disais voilà c'est eux qui vont
pouvoir juger donner les conseils faire
ce qu'il fallait
immo nomme secrétaire nationale à la
laïcité et nomme bianco à l'observatoire
est tous au cu c'est pareil j'ai été
très surpris j'étais pas candidat il m'a
dit je pense que tu as la reconnaissance
de qui tu es de ce que tu es une forme
de sagesse qui peut permettre peut-être
d'apaiser le débat
l'expérience a montré que ce n'est pas
si simple que ça à peine créé
l'observatoire de la laïcité est
critique et il est accusé de
sous-estimer l'influencent islamistes
regardons la réalité notre pays il
arrêter notre pays c'est que la grande
majorité de nos concitoyens vivent leur
foi ou leur absence de poids
tranquillement et sans poser de
problèmes
l'arrêté notre pays c'est aussi qu'il ya
des attaques contre la laïcité de ce
qu'on peut appeler l'islam politique
qu'il ne faut absolument pas laisser
passer
mais il n'y a pas une espèce de pieuvre
gigantesque qui s'en prend à la france
partout la france frappé la france
blessé douze morts
commun aujourd'hui de son histoire une
journée l'extrême sans son attaque
contre charlie hebdo et l'attentât le
plus meurtrier en plus les terroristes
inédit avec des lanières
[Musique]
charbon tu as été assassinés comme tu le
pressentait par nos plus anciens ne plus
plus est nous plus constant nos plus
bornés ennemis les fanatiques religieux
est un sanglant qui vocifèrent de tu
t'en as pas l'intelligence de la mort
ils n'auront jamais le dernier mot
donc il s'en trouvera pour continuer
notre inépuisable révision beaucoup trop
de gens oublient que sont la laïcité on
serait pas là à discuter tranquillement
et j'ai moins peur des extrémistes
religieux que des laïcs qui se taisent
toute rédaction qui serait massacrés
pour les idées qu'elle a exprimé
évidemment qu'on est avec elle
évidemment mais cela n'empêche pas
d'être intelligent
cela n'empêche pas de réfléchir de
réfléchir au delà des assassins eux même
qu'elle ait tous ce contexte qui produit
ces crimes qui fait que ces crimes
arrive
et quelle est la responsabilité de
gouvernants qui ne s'attaque pas à la
cause
on a milité toutes ces années là pour
empêcher pour empêcher ça en fait
et là en l'occurrence les frères kwasi
c'est de jeunes dont la névrose social a
été instrumentalisée monter monter en
épingle la haine pour armer leurs bras
et c'est notre défaite à c'est notre
défaite à toutes et tous parce qu'on n'a
pas été capable de faire reculer les les
manipulateurs qui les ont qu'il est qui
les ont car on fait des criminels
[Musique]
c'est un moment unique incroyable par la
masse de la population pour être à pau
français
et pourtant mes yeux tout cela des amis
les copains qui viennent d'evry est vrai
sont bondées nous disent y'a pas la
banlieue il ya une partie de la banlieue
est quelque chose qui est quelque chose
qui manque surtout parce qu'il ya une
peur
une souffrance les noms parfois aussi
chez certains des de pouvoir être
identifiées à ceux qui ont commis ces
attentats ignobles nom de la religion
l'immense masse des musulmans de france
n'ont rien à voir avec ça si on ne
comprend pas l'humiliation quotidienne
dans laquelle ont grandi des millions de
citoyens et citoyennes françaises dans
ce pays
on ne comprend pas l'hyper sensibilité
que ressentent un certain nombre de
musulmans ou de houe de musulmanes
d'ailleurs de culture musulmane ou de
confession chemin de salaire je fais
croyons en ayant le sentiment qu'en fait
c'est toujours sur eux on vient déverser
le trop plein de rage de la société
française montreuil l'hôpital andré
grégoire des patientes qui refuse d'être
examinée par des médecins hommes
la multiplication des pratiques
rigoriste dans l'espace public plonge la
gauche dans la plus grande perplexité
comment en est on arrivé là les uns
s'accuse d'islamologie selon les autres
d'islamophobie
le mot islamophobe concentre toute la
controverse qui déchire la gauche la
france n'est-elle pas devenue un peu
islamophobe
il ne faut pas avoir peur de se faire
traiter d'islamophobe qui a été si vous
voulez pendant pas mal d'années
comment dirais-je le le stop absolue
l'interdiction de parler hélas est
presque la suspicion sur la laïcité
c'est uniquement un débat étymologique
d'islamophobie uno ce débat de postures
et les gens qui en effet elisabeth
badinter a raison sur ce plan la taxe
d'islamophobe toute critique de l'islam
et de l'autre côté des gens qui sont en
fait la nouvelle orthodoxie de pensée
qui est de dire que l'islam c'est mal
c'est mauvais c'est dangereux c'est pas
compatible avec la république vous avez
deux orthodoxie de pensée pour vous
empêcher de réfléchir
jean louis bianco dit l'essentiel peu
importe les mots l'essentiel c'est qu'on
a le droit d'avoir sa religion et on a
le droit de critiquer une religion mais
on n'a pas le droit
de faire de la critique d'une religion
une obsession n'a pas le droit de faire
de la critique d'une religion le le next
russe ultra de la politique française et
on a d'autant moins le droit quand y
compris par des campagnes publicitaires
par exemple groupe publicis ont fait les
campagnes de l'arabie saoudite qui est
le foyer de l'islamisme radical
enfin de qui se moque t'on ça fait rien
et continue il continue à nier la
dangerosité d'un phénomène d'un
phénomène qui menace de dislocation les
états de droit les états de droit
moi je l'appelle racisme anti musulman
point final moi je récupère pas des mots
qui ont été balancés dans la vie
politique pour pouvoir aussi nous
museler sur le fait de critiquer les
religions qu'on condamne très timidement
les actes anti musulmans parce qu'il
faut surtout pas prononcer le mot
islamophobie et dans le même temps on
vient alimenter le discours islamophobe
le discours qui vise les musulmans en
les stigmatisant sur la question de la
laïcité
au fil des années les signes de
radicalisation sont de plus en plus
visible dans certains quartiers
populaires
la fracture de la gauche se creuse
manuel valls n'en finit pas de durcir
ses positions laïque il vote avec la
droite l'interdiction du voile intégral
seul contre l'avis de l'ensemble de la
gauche il prod même le bannissement du
voile à l'université
il se distingue enfin en 2016 alors
qu'il est premier ministre
une trentaine de communes du littoral
ont pris des arrêtés municipaux anti
burqini la polémique divise le
gouvernement
je pense qu'il ya là une dérive qui est
dangereux c'est arrêtées ne sont pas
dire les arrêtés anti burqini libère la
parole raciste et non non non ça c'est
une mauvaise interprétation
c'est toujours le même débat je veux
bien que ceux accusés d'être islamophobe
que on lie trop loin ça peut être le cas
je reconnais humblement mais il ya une
forme de lâcheté à ne pas reconnaître
que ce sont des provocations alors après
ce qu'il faut légiférer sur tout
évidemment non qu'il faut courir surtout
les sur tout ce qui sort
non mais c'est pour moi dire attention
on fait attention on est face à une une
provocation
quelques kilomètres de là où a lieu sur
la promenade des anglais
l'un des attentats les plus le plus
affreux qu'on ait connu pas seulement en
france mais en europe
la marche contre l'islamophobie a
mobilisé 13 mille cinq cents personnes
dans les rues de la capitale
les socialistes sont absents le numéro
un du parti communiste a lui aussi
boycotter la manifestation jugeant le
terme d'islamophobie ambiguë moi je suis
pas allé et j'ai pas rappeler à et allez
ça c'est sûr je n'ai pas signé cet appel
à manifester parce que je les ai lues
attentivement faut mieux consignes en
appel et il parlait de lois liberticides
en parlant des lois françaises donc je
ne considère pas que les lois sur la
laïcité sont des lois liberticides et
donc je n'ai pas signé je n'ai pas
participé à cette manifestation dans le
tohu bohu qui a préparé la manifestation
du 10 novembre pour ma part j'ai fait
mon choix d'être du côté de ces gens
humiliés abandonnés montrés du doigt
pour leur dire eh bien nous sommes
français grâce à la république française
et à la laïcité
vous ne serez pas persécutés pour votre
religion et les gens venaient de tous
côtés me touche et m'a prouvé en me
disant c'est bien que vous soyez là ils
savent qui je suis et qu'est ce que je
défends dans l'histoire et dans ce
papier ne distingue plus comme il le
distinguer avant les laïcs des non
laïque et donc quand il va à la marche
contre l'islamophobie avec des
intégristes une marche organisée par des
intégristes par les ennemis jurés de
charlie hebdo
bien sûr qu'il renie la vigilance qui
nous avait promise à l'enterrement de
charb
il me fait dire qu'il peut pas y avoir
de conciliation montre entre ces gauches
parfois il y a des positions
irréconciliables à gauche je l'avais dit
notamment quand mélenchon explique que
françois hollande
nicolas sarkozy après charlie et surtout
après le bataclan peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu renverser la table et ont appelé à
l'unité nationale parce que ça en valait
la peine tellement la société étaient
divisés face à cette force du peuple
français
nous n'avons pas été à la hauteur pour
proposer de la formule politique qui va
peut-être changer les choses
[Musique]
[Rires]
où
ce qu'il faut faire pour s'en sortir est
extraordinairement difficile à faire
parce que plus les jours passent et plus
c'est difficile
et j'ose à peine vous dire parce que ça
me fait une crève le coeur qu'il me
semble que dans certains quartiers c'est
trop tard je ne vois pas comment ça peut
se passer bien et sans violence voilà
moi j'ai l'habitude de dire sans vouloir
être pessimiste on l'a perdu ce combat
alors bon je vais pas à paraphraser
quelqu'un mais j'espère que c'est un
qu'une bataille qu'on a perdu et que on
va à d'autres que cas de victoire qui
nous attendent mais je vous avoue je
suis très très très pessimiste ç'a
toujours été difficile ne croyez pas que
ça va devenir simple parce que vous avez
proféré sur le ton du commandement une
règle vous vous trompez et si vous
oubliez un seul jour qu'au point de
départ de tout ça il ya l'affect humain
c'est-à-dire cette idée que nous sommes
semblables par nos besoins et donc égaux
en droits si vous perdez l'idée que
c'est une dimension affective
alors vous êtes à côté de vos pompes
vous êtes comme tous les allumeurs de
boucher
si j'ai un conseil à donner à la gauche
émancipatrice et bien c'est qu'elle
veuille bien s'intéresser plus à
l'histoire de lempire l'histoire de la
nationalité à l'histoire qui fait que
nos compatriotes qui sont issus de cette
histoire trouve leur passent leur place
comme citoyen de la république
la majeure partie des gens de ce pays
ils ont envie de vivre ensemble mais
pour qu'on vive ensemble
faut arrêter de faire que la question
des mémoires rs et restent cachés reste
tabou ça et ces moments là c'est l'heure
de faire le grand déballage faut faut
sortir les archives faut faut parler de
faut parler de la guerre d'algérie ont
parlé jusqu'à plus soif pour jusqu'à
rendre inopérant justement l'argument de
la de la mémoire coloniale faut parler
de l'esclavagé les colères des gens
qu'on subit ça elle ne soit pas exploité
par par des summer dance et notre boulot
les deux gauches qui semble aujourd'hui
et réconciliables leçon de ne toujours
pas avoir trouvé le moyen d'accorder
deux exigences fondamentales la défense
de l'opprimé et la promotion de la
liberté du féminisme de l'émancipation
[Musique]
la fêlure est d'autant plus profonde
qu'il s'agit d'une fêlure intime qui
traverse non seulement la gauche mais
bien souvent chaque citoyen
individuellement
[Musique]